alright this is our second round filming
our first review of we're so excited to
see fan for stick is everybody cold
arrives already prepped up here as you
can see I got whisky well then bring the
buck according to Simon Kinberg on
adapting the Fantastic Four comic books
in the film this Fantastic Four movie is
sort of a celebration of all the
Fantastic Four comics that have preceded
it do we see the same trailer only
remember the trailer looking like the
hand give me that some ha I don't think
that's what we're gonna see we're just
gonna start watching it so here we go
Tony Century Fox we finally made a
decent x-men movie starring no x-men
much - oh they emphasized the app like
it said the eggs oh that's stupid
a horse shadow of things to come yeah
Fantastic Four junkyards brooding music
really fantastic do we end up in the
explorers reboot right now I imagine is
like Doc Brown's device back in the Wild
West it's just gonna make a block of ice
awesome I made weed let's have an
opening honestly yeah and that's what
concerns me
it modulates the frequency of matter
from one location to another back again
it's a teleporter
oh come I could follow that how good
teacher not follow that was this free
Betsy DeVos or post you're disqualified
uh excuse me so many questions he blew
up the basketball thing even if you
don't think that plane went into the
desert he did that yeah he fucking did
that
fuck you Homer Symphony fucking did that
you just go to kits fairs huh yes do you
think this is how NASA works are we
gonna get into space school fair aha
this paper mache volcano taught me
everything that's gonna be the stink one
he's the muscle
yeah he looks really muscular really
gonna turn the lights on at school just
plants I just walked through the hallway
yes
an interesting Blair for music no I hate
it hate music just build yourself an
inflatable woman are you this mr.
fantastic Thank You Victor going doing
this on here and can't take seriously
deserves another chance give to him
another chance I'm just waiting for this
movie like punch me in the face so far
this is not gone awful nor at hood or
any glitch peace it doesn't get
ducktales what if me bank bikes it's fun
doing an equation so the volcano oh my
god I made a baking soda volcano
Reverend I was five steps ahead of this
movie it's trying to be all meta by like
well we're going to make fun of the fact
that this guy spouting cliches by having
the other characters make fun of the
cliches but really you're still using a
bunch of cliches actually making it more
obvious that you're falling back and
question there can't be Johnny Storm why
cuz he's black no because he's not that
way why do you need to make fun of his
name his natural had already made pot
houses science montage science your day
typing music going dee dee dee dee doo
doo doo doo ha ha Chinese that says they
have time to like social you Chinese and
laugh but uh my character yeah that's
the word I used to do have our nation
yet did they share a line of dialogue
yeah your since we ate Chinese we left
that's ponderize I think thought I'd say
this but can we get Von Doom in the
silly outfit already you know thank god
these superhero things happen to people
named storm and do my me if it just
happened to a guy named Bob answers to
questions we don't even know to ask you
like will there be a sequel no I could
use some drink
oh you said it buddy turn on a light
fuck
we're not always gonna have my back oh
not me I'm like two pounds
she's taller than him how have you gotta
have his back I'm sorry this forehead
fuckin oh my god oh my god
here we're making the jokes before
another half a day no but you know what
that's a problem if I say he looks like
Borat and then they mention that he will
quit Boris then the movies just stating
the obvious it's like a waterboy where
they make the teacher look like Colonel
Sanders and I'm like 20 minutes in it's
like he called Colonel Sanders ha ha
like yeah we all saw that and got that
like immediately give a bitching on
y'all service a having their faces
covered is not good because we can't see
their expressions but it's so dark
anyway we wouldn't see him regardless
Christ is that not interesting not an
interesting world sure why not let's
just walk on it this is why you didn't
go this is why we didn't send you your
best ain't it yeah ha something run
there's finally something in this movie
man it's been like an hour I didn't
expect plot to happen oh no power went
out of New York I'd never seen that
before in any comic book movie can you
suck your own dick we've been asking
that question since you got here we're
so Jarius can you stick your own head up
your ass
can you strangle yourself with your own
neck like we got a bit like to start
free food of duties do we just get to
skip all the scenes where they have to
like kind of react and deal with their
powers and like a so kind of know Susan
storms like fuck you asshole ha ha ha
these powers because you dicks went into
this thing like 3 was doing sciency
things and I did my science e things and
then I get shit yeah I can't tell she's
pissed off her that's just her normal
one like everyone else we're when Johnny
was like the show-off and fun and goofy
and what's even his character did what
any of their characters he watching the
movie we wish we were watching that one
even a bright sunny day that bright
sunny day was the color of puke being in
this movie yes
can i brewed with you this is a line
that defines this fucking movie you made
it ugly like smile and hey smile bro
take a shot here's my sorry the only
fucking shot I do during this whole
thing need to listen to dig deep listen
you and that's what got me here in the
first place
I agree there's way too much listening
in this movie yes we have a visual
can you describe it no it's
uninteresting wait we have a new visual
kind of silly
he turned into Mecca turtle they're
fuckin playing of really inferior versus
exact something I am the crash killed
dummy
furries used to stretchy power to push
people and jump over a rail fantastic
jeepers Campbell black God how do you
stop it I do but like I guess I should
destroy the world I guess it's so much
better if on doom head like the points
marked here oh my god I can't believe
you guys still trying to say hello giant
rock I only have like a million rocks to
throw it this time huh okay keep trying
it what this game cookin superhero team
no ok at work now where you said I'm out
you know I I wasn't gonna do anybody to
set it up so I'm totally gonna stop that
don't fool you what what just happened I
don't know I don't know but we did it
together hooray we did that we did but
you gotta Sarge
[Music]
really three people worked on the
screenplay and it was produced by seven
people and it's some hunting come out
good
you don't say Philip Glass what those
glasses ruminant yeah well let's be
honest have you ever really started you
know and it's like the movie itself is
so embarrassed to be fantastic for that
they could never verbally say it out
loud until the very end it's a that's
right at the movie all three of them
seem like perfectly decent actors so
it's not like I'm soon they're going
like oh it is bad no subscription even
no wine is to chew on I much rather have
something take a risk and fail than
something played safe bland not
interesting all the way through because
at least the failure will leave an
impact I will play the first movie left
morning in page yeah I remember that I'm
just I don't remember how bad yeah you
have that's about it and uh we'll see
you next time
fight
you